foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
we're with three little kittens with
Fleur all brushed said we can't sleep we
feel too rushed wow this is garbage do
you actually like this illumination the
studio that got you Despicable Me
The Secret Life of pets
feel heroic and handsome
a little wet but I still look good the
Grinch
You're a Mean One Mister sing
[Music]
oh yes I'm fine thank you
how are you minions
[Music]
[Applause]
and the Super Mario Brothers movie
there's a huge Universe out there
this Christmas illumination brings you a
film for the entire family
here we go tail for the torsion check
Wing deployment
let's fly
migration
We're not gonna make it are we Uncle Dan
[Music]
foreign